ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกๆคนก็
เกาะวันนี้ก็กลับมาเจอกับเรา 2 คนใช่ไหม
เราสองคนอีกแล้ว
เร็วๆดีใจค่ะใน Class  B  Tuner เนาะนี้
รักฮะอินเนอร์เงินนะเอาอีกอินเนอร์ไหม
ดีจริงๆน้อดินเน้อเธอแบบพื้นเลเวล 1 วัย
วุ่น
นักใครฟ้า
วันนี้หรอวันนี้ว่างอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะค่ะวันจันทร์น้องวัน
จันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะครูฟ้าอ่ะวันที่ 18
ค่ะ
เดือนอะไร
เดือน
ตุลาคม
เดือนตุลาคมเนาะปีพตตปีไทยเนาะปีพตอะไรคะ
อีผช
[เพลง]
2564 ค่ะหนึ่งแล้วปีคศอะไรคะ
และเมื่อวานนี้เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะวันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะครูฟ้าวันอาทิตย์ที่ 17 กับเดือน
อะไรคะเดือนตุลาคมปีพขอศ.
2564 ปีคศ
21 ค่ะค่ะแล้วให้นี้ล่ะคะพรุ่งนี้วัน
อะไร
พรุ่งนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 19 กึ่งจะ 20
19 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนตุลาคมปีพตต
2564 แล้วปีคศล่ะคะ
2021 ค่ะ
ก็เป็น
วันนี้ใช่ไหมวันนี้อันนี้คือวันนี้วันนี้
วันนี้เนี่ยวันจันทร์ในวันนี้วันจันทร์
เมื่อวานนี้และวันอาทิตย์
หน้านกมันพรุ่งนี้
พรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
เดี๋ยวก็วันนี้ใช่ไหมวันนี้เนี่ยวันนี้
เราสองคนก็มีวีดีโอสมัยอัดวีดีโอเมื่อวาน
เมื่อวานเนี่ยวันอาทิตย์เราสองคนเนี่ยอัด
วีดีโอไหมคะ
เมื่อวานวันอาทิตย์เราสองคนนะไม่อัด
วีดีโอค่ะ
ไม่มีล่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอังคารเราสองคนจะอัด
วีดีโอไหมคะเราสองคนจะอัดวีดีโอค่ะ
แปลว่าวันนี้ใช่ไหมกลับพรุ่งนี้เราสองคน
อ่ะวีดีโอไม่ใช่ดู Open  Server ไทยไหม
เขาเอาไทยที่สูงแล้ววันนี้หรอวันนี้นะคะ
ครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่นกี่โมง
วันนี้ครูฟ้าตื่น
นึงนะคะ
ru5
[เพลง]
ไม่รู้ 6 โมงหมูคริสต์วันนี้ครูฟ้าตื่น
6:00 นให้ห่า
แล้วเมื่อวานนี้น่ะคะเมื่อวานนี้ครูฟ้า
เนี่ยตื่นกี่โมง
เมื่อวานนี้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่นเต้น
แต่
10:00 นค่ะโอ้โห
วันนี้ตื่น
6:00 นเมื่อวานนี้ตื่น
10:00 นต้องอ่ะ
วันนี้ใช่ไหม
วันนี้นะเมื่อวาน
แล้วพรุ่งนี้ล่ะครับพรุ่งนี้ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยจะตื่นกี่โมง
พรุ่งนี้ครูฟาคิดว่าครูฟ้าจะตื่น
7:00 นค่ะอ๋อ
7:30 นเขา 7:30 น 7:30 นหมอ
7:30 นพรุ่งนี้ครูฟ้าคิดว่าคุณครูฟ้า The
ตื่น
7:30 น 8:30 นคิตั๋วยังไม่รู้ยังไม่ใช่
พรุ่งนี้ใช่หาแล้วผู้หญิงล่ะหาวันนี้ครู
หญิงตื่นกี่โมงนะวันนี้เนี่ยครูหญิงตื่น
8:00 นค่ะหูวันนี้ตื่น
8:00 น
8:00 นเมื่อวานครูหญิงตื่นกี่โมงคะเมื่อ
วานนี้ครูหญิงตื่นแหละ
9:00 น
ตื่น 9:00 นหนู
แล้วพรุ่งนี้ผู้หญิงคิดว่าครูหญิงจะตื่น
กี่โมง
พรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้วันอังคารใช่ไหมคะพรุ่ง
นี้เนี่ยคิดว่าก็น่าจะตื่นประมาณ
08:00 นเหมือนกัน
เหมือนวันนี้
ว่าผู้หญิงก็ตื่น 08:00 นบ่อยๆใช่ไหมวัน
ทรายค่ะแล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่นหกโมงใช่ไหมคะ
วันนี้แล้ววันนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าคิดว่าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยจะนอน
นอนเนี่ยกี่โมง
นอนกี่โมงเหรอขอเช็คก่อนนะคะเช็คอ้ะว่า
ถามเช็คอะไรมาเช็คอะไร
ฟ้ามีอะไรที่ต้องเช็คนะคะวันนี้ครูฟ้าคิด
ว่า
ครูฟ้าจะนอนกี่โมงนอนใช่
โอเคครูฟ้าจันทร์นอน
เปิด
11:00 น
ที่เป็นไทยแล้วกันนะพุ่ม
บุ๊ค
แล้วเมื่อวานนี้เมื่อวานนี้ครูฟ้าแน่นอน
นอน
23:00 นไหมคะเมื่อวานนี้เมื่อวานนี้กู
ฟ้านอน 23:30 นค่ะอ๋ออ๋อไม่ได้นอน 11:00
นใช่ไหมนอน
23:30 น
แล้วพรุ่งนี้ครูฟ้าคิดว่าครูฟ้าจะนอนกี่
โมง
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าครูฟ้าสระนอน 22:00 นค่ะ
จะนอนเร็วใช่ไหมคะเพราะว่าง่วง
ชัวร์เลยค่ะว่ากูไปจะม่วงเพราะว่าวันนี้
นอน 23:00 นเมื่อวานนี้นอนมาไกลคิดพรุ่ง
นี้นอน 22:00 นดีกว่าดีกว่าใช้แล้วครู
หญิงแล้ววันนี้ครูหญิงนอนกี่โมงวันนี้ครู
หญิงเนี่ยน่าจะนอน
22:00 นค่ะ
22:00 นทุ่ม
เมื่อวานคะเมื่อวานแล้วมันหมู่เมื่อวาน
เนี่ยผู้หญิงนอนปั๊มประมาณ
ถ้าถ้า
19:30 นกู
มา 19:30 นท้ายแล้วพรุ่งนี้ล่ะคะพรุ่งนี้
ครูหญิงคิดว่าควีนจะนอนกี่โมงพรุ่งนี้
เนี่ยคิดว่าจะนอนเหมือนวันนี้ก็คือ
22:00  -  22:00 นค่ะ
[เพลง]
โอเคตายจำวันดีหมอเหมือนครูฟ้าพรุ่งนี้
ครูป่าก็นอน 22:00 นผู้หญิงก็นอน 22:00 น
เหมือนกัน
ง่วงหมดนู้น
งวยแล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยเมื่อวานเมื่อวานนะ
เมื่อวานเนี่ยครูฟ้าเนี่ยนอนกี่ชั่วโมง
[เพลง]
อ้วนตื่น 10:00 นใช่ไหมเมื่อวานเนี่ยครู
ฟ้าใช่ไหม 10:00 นตื่นๆมั่วกูมันน้อยกี่
โมงนะนอน 23:00 นป่ะ 11:00 นนะงวดนั้น
กุ้งหมานอน 23:00 นถึง 10:00 นเมื่อวาน
ครูฟ้านอนกี่ชั่วโมงโห
และก็นับไปเนาะมานอน 23:00 น
24:00 น 1:00 น 2:00 น 3:00 น 4:00 น
5:00 น 6:00 น 7:00 น 8:00 น 9:00 น
10:00 นครูฟ้านอน 11 ชั่วโมงเมื่อวานครู
ป้านอน 11
จริงๆแล้วฟ้าเนี่ยนอนนิดหน่อยนะคะก็เลย
ง่วงไงเมื่อวานทะเลนอนมันนกนักเรียนเนาะ
แล้วค่ะนอน 11 ชั่วโมงแล้ววันนี้วันนี้
ครูฟ้านอนกี่ชั่วโมง
วันนี้ครูป้านอน 5 ทุ่มครึ่งเนาะจ่ายไฟ
ฟ้าเนี่ยนอน
23:30 นอุ้ยตื่น 6 ช่วงโค้งก็ 5 ทุ่ม
เที่ยงคืนตี 1 ตี 2 ตี 3 ตี 4 ตี 5  6
โมงก็ประมาณ 6 ชั่วโมงครึ่งไหมครูฟ้านอน 6
ชั่วโมงครึ่งนะ 6 ชั่วโมงครึ่งนแล้วพรุ่ง
นี้พรุ่งนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าคิดว่าครูฟ้าได้
อยากจะนอนกี่ชั่วโมง
จริงๆเข้านี้ครูมาคิดว่ากูไฟล์อยากนอน 8
ชั่วโมงค่ะแข
ฟ้าอยากนอนแต่ชั่วโมงพรุ่งอย่างนี้นะนอน
เยอะๆนอนเยอะๆแล้วครูหญิงหรอหาวันนี้ครู
ผู้หญิงจะนอนกี่ชั่วโมงวันนี้วันนี้กู
หญิงจะนอน 22:00 นใช่ไหมทุ่ม
4 ทุ่มเนาะ 10:00 นแต่ผู้หญิงจะนอนแล้ว
ก็จะตื่น
8 โมงก็แล้วก็ตื่น 8:00 นอ่ะอ่าวันนี้
ผู้หญิงนอนกี่ชั่วโมงไก่ 5 ทุ่มเที่ยงคืน
1:00 น 2:00 น 3:00 น 4:00 น 5:00 น 6:00
น 7:00 น 8:00 นขลุ่ยนอน
10 ชั่วโมง
นอน
อะไรขนาดนี้
คุณเยอะนอน
พบดอนใช่ไหมโอเคนะนนท์ชั่วโมง
แล้วเมื่อวานเหรอเมื่อวานครูหญิงนอนกี่
ชั่วโมงคะเมื่อวานคุยอีกนอน 23:30 นใช่
ไหมคะตื่น
ที่ 9 โมงเพราะตื่น 09:00 นก็ห้าทุ่ม
ครึ่ง 23:00 น 24:00 น 1:00 น 2:00 น 3:00
น 4:00 น 5:00 น 6:00 น 7:00 น 8:00 น
9:00 น
ก็แต่ละ 9 ชั่วโมงครึ่งใช่ไหม
9  9 ชมครึ่ง 9 ชั่วโมงครึ่งเมื่อวาน
เมื่อวานแล้ว
พรุ่งนี้เหรอพรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้ผู้หญิงอยาก
นอนกี่โมง
พรุ่งนี้กูหญิงอยากนอนกี่ชั่วโมงพรุ่งนี้
คุณก็คิดว่าครูหญิงได้อยากจะนอน
10 ชั่วโมง
10 ชั่วโมงเหมือนวันนี้
นอนเยอะๆตื่นก็ได้แบบ
ร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์อ่ะใช้ดีมากเลยค่ะแล้ว
เมื่อวานเจอไหมเมื่อวานเนี้ยครูฟ้ากิน
อะไรคะเมื่อวานครูฟ้ากินข้าวใช่ไหมเมื่อ
วานครูฟ้ากินข้าวเนาะกินอะไรเมื่อวานมัน
ก็เมื่อวานครูขากินข้าวต้มค่ะ
เขาข้าวต้มข้าวต้มกุ้งใช่ไหมในรูปดีกุ้ง
ตายข้าวต้มกุ้ง
อ้า 10 วันนี้วันนี้ครูฟ้ากินอะไรคะ
วันนี้ครูฝากินผัดไทยค่ะโอ้โอ๋
อีกแล้วผัดไทยกุ้ง
กุ้งร่วงอ่ะเอ้าร่วงนะ
นี่ผัดไทยกุ้งผู้ช่วยมีกุ้ง
แล้วพรุ่งนี้ให้มีเนี่ยครู Fast คิดว่า
ครูฟ้าจะกินอะไรครูฟ้าสิว่าครูพาจะกินสุข
สุขอินทร์
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ท่านต่อย
ตู้ชี่สุจิท้ายเนี้ยอันนี้คือสุกี้
เป็นซุปใช่มั้ยลุกฮือ
เมื่อวานครูปาร์คอินน์กุ้ง
วันนี้ครูฟ้าก็กินกุ้ง
พรุ่งนี้ครูฟ้าจะกินกินกุ้งแสนกัน
กลุ่มเร็วเวอร์นะ
เบอร์โทรปคุง
ก็ไม่ตลก
แล้วผู้หญิงล่ะฮะ
วันนี้วันนี้ครูหญิงกินอะไรวันนี้ครูหญิง
กินต้มยำกุ้ง
ต้มยำกุ้งกุ้ง
อีกแล้ว
คนไทยชอบกินกุ้งหรออร่อยกุ้งกุ้งที่
ประเทศไทยแบบนี้
อร่อย
เหอะเหอะแมวเมื่อวานเมื่อวานนี้ครูหญิง
กินอะไรคะเมื่อวานขลุ่ยหญิงกินต้มข่าไก่
ไก่ไก่ไก่
เป็นต้มขาไก่
ไม่มีกุ้งกินไก่ต้มขาไก่
เตือนพรุ่งนี้ล่ะคะพรุ่งนี้ครูหญิงคิดว่า
ผู้หญิงจะกินอะไรเออพรุ่งนี้เนี่ยคิดว่า
จะกินข้าว
ข้าวผัดเหมือนเป็นข้าวนะเขามาผัดข้าวผัด
ใส่เข้าโพด
ใส่ถั่วลันเตาไม่ใส่แครอท not ข้าวผัดคิด
ว่าจะกินข้าวผัดค่ะ
โตทีเลยนะโอเคใช่แต่ว่าวันนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้า
กินผัดไทยใช่ไหมกินผัดไทยอร่อยฟ้าเนี่ย
กินผัดไทยวันนี้เนี่ยฝนตกไหม
วันนี้ฝนหรอกฝนมันไปท้องฟ้า
นะฝนตก
ฝนตกไหมคะค่ะวันนี้วันนี้ฝนตกค่ะ
ฝนตกไอ้ห่าแล้วเมื่อวานนี้เมื่อวานนี้ฝน
ตกไหมคะเมื่อวานนี้ฝนตกหน้า
ฝนตกมากๆเลยง้อแล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยบอกว่า
เมื่อวานเมื่อวานนี้ฝนตกวันนี้ฝนตกครู
Fast คิดว่าพรุ่งนี้
ฝนจะตกไหมพรุ่งนี้ฝนก็ตกค่ะกลัวคิดใช่ผู้
ฟ้ามีแอพพลิเคชั่นใช่ไหม
พรุ่งนี้ฝนจะตกถั่วนี้เองจะชัวร์อ๊ะป่าว
ว่า
100%  1 เปิดเสร็จพรุ่งนี้และแน่นอน
นั่นแหละอันนี้
ก็พัทยา
บ้าน
บ้านครูฟ้านะบ้านครู 3 เมื่อวานนี้ฝนตก
วันนี้ฝนตกพรุ่งนี้ครูฟ้าก็คิดว่าฝนตกถูก
ต้องนะหน้าแล้วนักเรียนหรอคะ
นักวันนี้
นักเรียนดูวีดีโอ
อะไร
นะวันนี้นักเรียนดูวีดีโออยู่ใช่ไหมน้อง
มดนักเรียนดูคลิปนี้นะคะก็แปลว่าวันนี้
นักเรียนฟังภาษาไทยแล้วก็ดูวีดีโอเราสอง
คน
เมื่อวานนักเรียนดูวีดีโอไหมคะเปปไทด์ไหม
ดูวีดีโอมั้ยนะวัน
พรุ่งนี้นักเรียนจะดูวีดีโอแล้วก็ฟังภาษา
ไทยไหมน้องทำเพ้นท์ได้นะวะวันนี้ดูวีดีโอ
เมื่อวานดูวีดีโอมั้ยและพรุ่งนี้จะดู
วีดีโอมั้ยอะไรบอกเราได้เนาะส่วนวันนี้
เราสองคนก็ต้องไปก่อนเนาะอ่อนเหรอแล้วก็
อย่าลืมทำอะไรอย่าลืมกด like กด Share กด
Subscribe ด้วยนะคะนักเรียนใช่แล้วค่ะ
แล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้าบ้างสวยน่า